de ne pas paniquer il en demeure pas
moins qu'un troisième cas d'ebola en
moins de trois semaines à dallas eh bien
on sent que la tension a monté d'un cran
ici et l'inquiétude
les gens se demandent qu'est ce qui se
passe les gens se demandent si les états
unis étaient vraiment prêt à faire face
à ce virus d'une très très grande
violence
derrière moi à les cours dans un des
quartiers de d'alice on se prépare à une
rencontre avec des citoyens dans ce
théâtre pour leur donner toute
l'information avec des professionnels de
la santé pour tenter justement de
rassurer la population en ce qui
concerne m
26 29 ans et 2e infirmières du
presbyterian hospital a contracté le
virus
elle était en route vers un hôpital
d'atlanta où elle sera pris en charge
parce qu'ici on nous dit que le
personnel du presbyterian hospital est à
bout de souffle et on semble extrêmement
exténué
donc elle sera pris en charge là-bas
tout près d'ailleurs du centre pour les
maladies infectieuses
alors la grande question ici est ce que
les états unis étaient vraiment prêt à
faire face à ce virus
eh bien on a rencontré un peu plus tôt
un médecin québécois qui travaille
depuis trente deux ans et six au texas
dans la région de dallas il nous dit il
ne faut pas trop sévère avec les
employés les infirmières les médecins
qui ont combattu ce virus depuis
quelques semaines mais il serait
peut-être préférable de penser songer
sérieusement à mettre un terme au vol en
provenance d'afrique de l'ouest
je pense que ce serait une excellente
idée pour le moment ce qui empêche pas
qu ils pourraient avoir des vols spécial
personnel médical équipements cetera
mais ça diminuerait beaucoup l'anxiété
ici aux etats-unis évidemment et pour
ajouter à cette anxiété générale cette
deuxième infirmière a contracté le virus
de l'ebola à voler a pris l'avion lundi
avec 132 passagers alors ses 132
personnes on leur demande là de se
déclarer pour qu'il soit la surveiller
afin de voir s'ils n'ont pas été
affectés eux également
le président obama qui doit s'adresser à
la nation qui doit parler aux américains
très bientôt amis
un terme à ses activités aujourd'hui et
il a rencontré les autorités médicales
pour voir justement qu'est ce qu'ils en
étaient précisément les situations à
dallas ici christian latreille
radio-canada à dallas